so i think any other period during the
queen's reign her deciding not to go to
sandringham would come as an enormous
shock but of course during these covered
times
nothing now is unexpected last year of
course she didn't travel to sandringham
and once again the same decision has
been made this year now i understand
that the decision was a personal one
made by her majesty herself
after some very careful consideration
and i think it reflects a very
precautionary approach um we understand
yes that she will instead be spending
christmas
at windsor there will we're told the
family visiting windsor over the
christmas period and that they will be
following all of the appropriate
guidelines that we're all being asked to
abide by over christmas whatever those
may be of course the prime minister only
in the last hour or so saying that he is
still looking at that data hour by hour
in terms of
what he may or may not have to do when
it comes to advice
around christmas gatherings but this
will be a big disappointment for the
queen no doubt
remember she doesn't just spend a week
the christmas week at sandringham this
is normally a prolonged stay she
normally doesn't return to either
buckingham palace or windsor
until early february after marking the
death the day that her father died so
around the 6th of february so the fact
that she spends a prolonged period of
time there it's seen as a really
important family occasion where they can
all spend a bit of time away together
also it's going to come as a massive
deployment disappointment for the the
hundreds sometimes thousands of people
who gather every christmas day just to
watch the members of family uh travel
and walk to church as well so again this
is going to be a disappointment for all
of those raw watchers who really enjoy
that moment every year but i think it
was a decision that um we expected to be
made around now this is usually the time
that the queen does travel to
sandringham um also don't forget the
royal family it's always throughout this
pandemic been about setting the right
example so in recent weeks they've been
pushing the vaccination message pushing
the message that people should have
their booster jab and while of course
those arrangements in terms of whether
or not the prime minister is going to
change the advice that is still pretty
much up in the air i think for the royal
family they did not want to encourage
crowds to gather at sandringham and also
if there is now a sense that households
are going to be encouraged not to mix
then the royal family certainly wants to
set the right example
in terms of who might be with the queen
on christmas day we're still not sure at
the moment we're still waiting for
guidance as to what exactly uh prince
charles and camilla are going to be
doing and what exactly the cambridges
are going to be getting up to but of
course we know that on the windsor
estate very close by you've got the earl
and council of wessex and their two
children they live very close by and of
course the yorks also live on the
windsor estate as well so we understand
the queen certainly will not be by
herself on christmas day